promixité vous est présenté par ngj
acteur engagé en faveur de l'égalité
[Musique]
professionnelle bonjour à tous et
bienvenue dans promixité l'émission qui
vous parle de la place des femmes dans
le monde du travail aujourd'hui focus
sur le métier d'influenceur largement
dominé par les femmes c'est ce qui
ressort du d' unee étude de la Fondation
reboot et du woman's forum qui est le
Davos féminin ainsi en 2021 85 % des
partenariats noué avec les entreprises
ont fait appel à des influenceuses des
influenceuses qui d'ailleurs facturent
quatre fois plus cher leur poste que les
hommes vu comme ça c'est donc un secteur
qui offre de nombreuses opportunités aux
femmes selon la présidente du woman's
forum mais attention au mirage 63 % des
adolescentes et 72 % des adultes
considèrent que les influenceuses
gagnent correct corctement leur vie
alors que 80 % d'entre elles ne
parviennent tout simplement pas à
subvenir à leurs besoins à noter par
ailleurs que 60 % des jeunes filles
reconnaissent que les influenceuses
pèsent sur leur opinion mais un bon
tiers à vous aussi se sentir découragé
voir angoissé en visionnant leur poste
voilà promic cité c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite sur
public
scena promixité vous a été présenté par
NG acteur engagé en faveur de égalité
professionnelle